CHRISTOPHER L.
EISGRUBER: I'd like
to tell you a bit about the
2019 Princeton Pre-read, a book
that I'm really excited about
by James Williams called
"Stand Out of Our Light: Freedom
and Resistance in the Attention
Economy."
I'm excited about
this book because it
talks about some
changes that have
been happening in
our lives in ways
that we almost haven't noticed.
Over the past decade or so,
we've all become dependent
on this digital technology
that's all around us now,
where we carry our
phones with us,
and if we ever happen to walk
out of our house without it
or misplace it,
all of a sudden we
feel like we've lost a
lifeline of some kind.
That digital technology
is having all kinds
of effects on our lives
that are terrific,
which is why we want those
phones and that access
to digital media
during our days.
But what James
Williams argues is
that they're also changing
our lives in other ways
that we haven't
come to appreciate.
And that in doing so,
they're reducing our ability
to focus on the ends and the
goals that really matter to us.
In the political
realm, for example,
with all sorts of messages
all over the place
and a competition
for viewership,
it's often the most
extreme messages
that get the most attention.
And it has this feeling
that I think all of us
notice around us of kind
of heating up democracy,
of making argument
and conversation more
volatile and often more
aggressive in character.
It's affecting our
politics, and it also
affects a lot of what we do here
in the university and the way
we pursue our ordinary lives.
So one of the things
that we do at University
is try to get people to take
the long-term perspective
and focus on ideas that
demand a lot of attention.
But there are studies now that
suggest that simply having
your phone on you the way
that I do, or even next to you
as you're reading a book, can
diminish the level of attention
that you're bringing
to that book.
So James Williams, in this
remarkable short book,
raises a series of questions
that I think all of us
need to be thinking about.
And I think Princeton
University is a great place
to be thinking about
these kinds of questions,
because we have an
intellectual tradition here
that brings together
subjects like technology,
and public policy, and ethics,
and the study of democracy.
So I'm really thrilled
to be including this book
in our Pre-read tradition.
Pre-read is something
that I created
as I took office six years ago.
We're now distributing it to
all of our entering graduate
students as well as our
entering undergraduates,
making it available to
others in the community who
are interested.
And I hope that alumni and
others and faculty and staff
will be joining the incoming
students and me as we
read this book and talk
about the set of issues
that it raises.